Figure skater Yu-na Kim joined the IOC in Lausanne on Wednesday...
...to help promote the first winter edition of the Youth Olympic Games.
As a special ambassador, the 21-year-old South Korean spoke of her excitement...
...to inspire the Olympic dream in young athletes.
She believes that communicating with young talent directly helps to give them confidence and belief in themselves.
So far, I've been working hard as an athlete to achieve my goal...
...and it's my great honor to play a role in inspiring young people to achieve their Olympic dreams.
So for the Innsbruck games, I am going to go there and also watch the games...
...and meet and talk with the young athletes there.
I want to give them the confidence and belief in themselves.
With the 2018 Winter Olympics coming to her home country,...
...Yu-na spoke of the importance of promoting figure skating in her native Korea and elsewhere in Asia.